[Music]
it took 10 years to film the 8 Harry
Potter films so we understand why a lot
of things change during this time
including actors but you'll have to
watch this video until the end to know
who had to be fired after being arrested
if you love Harry Potter as much as we
do don't freak to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today
we're showing you 10 Harry Potter actors
who were replaced in the sequels Valda
Mort after hearing everyone talking
about him we first got the chance to see
the face of balda Mort in Harry Potter
and the Philosopher's Stone after being
defeated by baby Harry the Dark Lord
finally got the opportunities to come
back on professor quirrell's heads this
is what made him a temporary Horcrux
after trying to steal the philosopher's
stone he was finally destroyed by Harry
Potter due to the protective power that
his mother left on his skin at that time
Ian Hurt didn't only play Professor
Quirrell he also provided the voice and
the facial source for the parasite
however when he was destroyed it made
sense that he had to find another body
and looked totally different this is why
he was been played by Ralph Fiennes from
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire to
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
don't worry the actor did have a nose
but it was removed in post-production
and he is also actually not evil at all
over the whole movie series the young
Tom Riddle was also played by Frank
Dillane at 15 years old hero finds
tiffin at 11 years old and Christian
Coulson at 16 years old and here's
Voldemort little secret Ralph Fiennes
admitted that he had to wear women's
tights a garter belt and suspenders
under his dark clothes will feel less
intimidated if we ever see him now that
we think about this lavender brown in
the first movies lavender was just a
random student in the background we
would probably think that she was just
an extra because she never talks but you
could actually see her name in the
credits with the name lavender Brown the
casting director had in mind that her
skin was brown and it was too hard to
find a young actress with lavender skin
moreover it was their way to show a
little bit of diversity with a cast who
is mainly white this is why in Harry
Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban the
minor character was played by a
child actress Jennifer Smith but when
the young witch finally got more
attention they decided to cast someone
else we understand that a girl who used
to have a minor role was not ready for
such a big role but the filmmakers made
a big mistake when they decided to hire
a white girl instead Jessi cave they
could have easily found another black
actress with more experience and we
wouldn't even notice the difference but
they went for someone who couldn't look
more different this is why they were
accused of whitewashing even though the
new actress was perfect for this role
casting directors seemed to think that
people of color belong in the background
while white people get more
opportunities however they did make
things a little better by casting a
black Hermione in Harry Potter and the
cursed child Albus Dumbledore when we
first met the principal of Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry she
was played by the amazing Richard Harris
surprisingly he first declined the offer
to have a role in Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone
but his granddaughter told him that she
would never speak to him again if he
didn't take this role so he finally
agreed and we think that it was one of
the best decisions of his entire career
Harris looked just like the Dumbledore
that we all imagines when we were
reading the books unfortunately he
passed away at the age of 72 two years
before the premiere of the second movie
he was suffering from Hodgkin's disease
a type of lymphoma he was replaced by
Michael Gambon in the following movies
as the kids movies became darker it made
sense to replace the happy Dumbledore
with a more serious one but did you know
that Sir Ian McKellen from Lord of the
Rings could have had the chance to play
this role too but he said that Harris
described him as passionless and he
didn't want to take the place of an
actor who disapproved him during his
youth Dumbledore was also played by Toby
regbo
as we can see in Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows and we can't wait to see
what is going to happen to him in
fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald as he will be played by Jude
Law Griphook stanislofsky said that
there are no small parts only small
actors
but Warwick Davis proved that you can be
a small actor in the best way and have a
big role you probably remember Griphook
the goblin we met in green guts
Wizarding bank in Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone he was the one who
took Harry and
Hagrid to vaults 7:13 and 687 at that
time he was portrayed by Verne Troyer
who is famous for playing mini-me in the
Austin Powers films but what you might
not know is that he was voiced by
Warwick Davis who played Professor
Flitwick in the same movie however later
in the movie series the filmmakers
wanted a completely British cast this is
why Toyo was fully replaced by Warwick
Davis in Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows isn't it weird to see an actor
play two really different roles in the
same movie but with such heavy makeup
and a different voice we have to admit
that we never noticed it and we can't
find a lot of actors through our only
three feet six inches tall this is why
his wife his daughter and his son also
played goblins in the Harry Potter
series don't forget that your difference
always makes you stand out and this is
how it can become your greatest strength
the fat lady
we barely saw her but she was so
memorable that everyone remembers her
she was a portrait Hugh guarded the
entrance to Gryffindor Tower and asked
for passwords before letting anyone in
we don't even know her real name so we
hope that Elizabeth sprigs didn't take
it personally when she was cast in the
role of the fat lady and she wasn't
really overweight that's probably why
she was renamed the pink lady in one of
the video games it's true that we don't
know what we have until it's gone that's
because when the fat lady was ruined by
Sirius Black she was replaced by Sir
Cadogan and people really started
missing her but in the same movie she
was also replaced by Don French who
finally gave her a personality and
portrayed the character with a more
humorous side we all remember the scene
where she broke a glass with her voice
but there is something else in that
scene that only the biggest harry potter
fans noticed there was a painting of a
man that looks like Lord Voldemort
dancing to the sound of her voice it is
just hilarious to see him in this
position we know that it is probably not
him but what has been seen cannot be
unseen we'll think about this every time
we see the movie Hellena Ravenclaw the
ghost of the daughter of railway no ray
also known as the gray lady used to be a
minor character in the first Harry
Potter movies
she wasn't even named in the first book
but JK Rowling said that she was the
ghost of a tall which that Harry and Ron
saw however she did get a little more
attention in the first two movies at
that time she was also played by Mina
young they later offered the role to
Kate Winslet from Titanic but her agent
turned down the idea probably because it
is not really a big role it is in Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows that the
grey lady really became an important
character in the story she was the one
who stole her mother's diadem and hid it
in Albania before she was murdered by
the bloody baron by the way you have
seen this character too as he is a ghost
at Hogwarts isn't it weird to spend the
rest of your life or actually your death
with someone who ended your life by the
way do you know how you can become a
ghost only wizards who are afraid of
death can live an impoverished version
of life instead they are mostly people
who had some unfinished business in the
form of guilt regrets or attachment to
the material world being a ghost isn't
really a good choice don't you think
though Weasley
this character used to be so subtle that
we have almost forgotten about him even
though he was mentioned in the first
movies we only had the chance to see him
on one picture of the Weasley family in
Egypt in Harry Potter and the Prisoner
of Azkaban at that time he was portrayed
by Richard fish but he later got a
bigger role in Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows and was portrayed by
domhnall gleeson by the way did you know
that his father is Brendan Gleeson who
plays mad-eye moody this is why his
favorite line in the film was mad eyes
dead another great coincidence is that
in the books you can read that bill
looks like Mad Eye Moody when his scars
were as bad as ever and did you know how
he got those scars he was badly injured
by Fenrir Greyback
during the fight at the Astronomy tower
since Grayback was a werewolf
the wounds were cursed and they never
healed which explains the scars on his
face however he was not transformed at
that time so they were not contaminated
and Bill did not become a werewolf
however he did develop a liking for very
rare stakes
his injuries are also what convinces
mother that Fleur was the right one for
him as she stayed by his side no matter
what Tom now we're not talking about Tom
Riddle there was actually another Tom in
the Harry Potter series this man was the
landlord and barman at the leaky
cauldron we first met him in Harry
Potter in the Philosopher's Stone when
he greeted Hagrid and Harry at that time
he was played by Derek Dedmon Tom was
shown as a man with a straight back but
it suddenly changed in Harry Potter and
the Prisoner of Azkaban as he was
suddenly a hunchback this character was
played by Jim table array with such a
big difference many people started
wondering if they were actually two
different people with the same name who
happened to work at the leaky cauldron
it's also rare to see two people with
the same name in one story but some
people think that JK Rowling intended to
have two characters named Tom that's
because Tom Riddle hated his name as it
was too common and he wanted to be
independent he probably didn't like to
meet the other Tom when he first visited
Diagon Alley it could be one of the
reasons why he decided to call himself
Lord Voldemort the writer is such a
great perfectionist that she probably
thought about that Harry Potter
we know that Harry Potter was portrayed
by Daniel Radcliffe and don't worry
you're not crazy he did play this role
until the end of the movie but the actor
was a little too old to play himself as
a baby so they had to hire another actor
you have probably heard people saying
that the baby in the first Harry Potter
movie who's actually Albus Severus
Potter in Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows after all 10 years after it
would totally make sense that he would
be 11 years old but we are going to
prove that this is nothing but a fake
story first baby Harry wasn't only
played by one after but by four actors
in the first film he was played by three
unnamed babies the Saunders triplets the
funniest thing about it is that one of
them was a girl so it is possible that
the baby in the movie was not a boy and
Harry Potter's son Elvis was played by
Arthur Bowen in the last movie so there
is no link between the two families
moreover the baby in the viral picture
was actually the actor from the last
movie
Toby Packer we think that only one thing
can explain this crazy theory Rita
Skeeter has been writing fake news
in the muggle world vincent crabbe so
what happened to Crabbe and Harry Potter
he used to be knock boys best friends
and then he suddenly quit Hogwarts and
was replaced by someone else where did
Jamie way let go
he wasn't simply not interested in this
project anymore or replaced by another
actor he was actually fired from the
movie series that's because he was
arrested in 2009 for growing illegal
substances in his mother's home and
pleaded guilty then he had to pay a fine
and was sentenced to six weeks in a
young offenders institution two years
after he was arrested again for taking
part in the London 2011 riots because he
was seen holding something dangerous and
also stole something this is why he was
charged with two years in prison for
violent disorder at the same time Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows was
released and we could see a new actor
Luis Cortez actually he was still
supposed to play Blaise zambini but we
can still say that he took krabs place
in the movie this is how another actor
ended up passing away in the Room of
Requirement in the last movie and it
left anyone who read the book really
confused do you agree with the choices
that the casting directors made don't be
shy to answer in the comment section
down below we'd love to hear what you
think and that's it for 10 Harry Potter
actors who were replaced in the sequels
for more stories like this make sure you
watch this is how the cast of Harry
Potter should have really looked thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]